We arrived in England yesterday,
and I've been craving Persian food all day long,
so when I found out they had a Persian restaurant on the property,
I obviously had to go. I've been obsessed with ginger ale lately,
and after looking at the menu,
we went with the two different kinds of flat breads
and their signature black garlic hummus and eggplant dip.
They were both so delicious,
and I couldn't stop eating them.
And even though I love the hummus,
there was something so good about the eggplant.
It was perfectly smoky, but also slightly sweet.
For the main course, I got the lamb kebab,
and the boys got chicken.
We also got some rice Frazzi salad and torchy sauce.
This plate was absolute perfection.
The lamb was so juicy, the rice was perfect.
I love a good shirazi salad.
I also tried the boys chicken,
which also was delicious.
And this bread that was sitting under all the meat,
soaking up all the juices.
I'm still thinking about it,
even though I was stuffed and bursting at the seams.
I finished off the salad, but then gave the meat and rice to the boys.
They ordered another round of flat breads for all the leftover dips.
I obviously had to have another bite,
but then I was done and needed something sweet.
So we headed over to the main restaurant,
where I got some hot chocolate,
vanilla and salted caramel ice cream, which was just divine.